I think a lot of people have a hard time
letting go of this idea that mathematics
is just ultimately describing some
relationships between stuff that's
fundamentally non-mathematical if you're
in a computer game there is no actual
stuff in pac-man right it's the entire
nature of pac-woman or these little
things you gobble up or the monsters or
just relationships between abstract
things that have no intrinsic properties
at all there's you know no actual stuff
there and in the same way I think this
is what we've learned about a physical
world it's the relationships that really
really matter between things in the
world and yes that's ultimately all
there is the entities themselves have no
properties except the relationships that
they have that's not that different in
some sense from our thoughts and the
subjective experiences they feel a
little bit more ethereal you know than a
book or an apple but it's the
relationship between the different
pieces of information yes they give it
the texture and subjective properties
yes the we're so fond of in the stimuli
that comes in from the exterior and yeah
from our throw the entirety of our path
of life yeah until yeah there's no mind
that's exactly yours receiving the exact
same stimuli and also if you think you
ask yourself why is it that the sound of
Oh
subjective feels very different from say
that experience of the color red you
know it's not anything that they were
the outside world it's actually
represented in the brain and very
similar ways electrical firings of
neurons that you could it's hard to tell
the difference between them and the
microscope the reason one feels like a
sound and one feels like the visual
experience just has to do with its
relation with other pieces of
information when it's in your brain and
you can have all that experience even
when you're not looking you're hearing
the world at all when you're sleeping
and dreaming right yeah it still feels
the same